or have less than a high school
education with unemployment those
without a high school diploma dropped
the full three point three percentage
points that's the largest drop in
recorded history
eighty percent of small businesses are
now open eighty percent and we think
we're going to have some very good
numbers in the coming months because
others are opening and especially as we
put the flame out getting rid of the
flame it's happening new business
applications have doubled since late
March that's a number that is not even
thinkable to achieve this early into a
pandemic the latest is M manufacturing
report rose ten percentage points with
new orders jumping a remarkable twenty
five percentage points or a record
consumer confidence which is great
that's a great number to me because that
means confidence is really good if you
don't have good consumer confidence it's
like life if you don't have confidence
you're not gonna do very well consumer
confidence has risen twelve points since
April and six months job expectations
hit the all-time an all-time high so
think of that for a second with all we
go through with all of the trials and
tribulations that we read about every
night much of it totally fake news
fortunately and if the consumer didn't
get it you wouldn't have good consumer
confidence we have consumer confidence
has risen twelve points since April an
all-time high
think of that retail sales surged and
asan astonishing eighteen percent so
retail sales went up an astonishing
eighteen percent in May that's the
largest increase in the history of our
country that's a tremendous number
eighteen percent the number of and what
it means to me is jobs the number of
unemployed Americans re-entering the
labor force rose by forty three percent
and fewer workers are dropping out of
the labor force than before and the
crisis is being handled in all of you
look we were talking this morning
something to think about China was way
early and they're getting under control
just now and Europe was warily and
they're getting under control we
followed them with this terrible China
virus and we are likewise getting under
control some areas that were very hard
hit we're now doing very well
some were doing very well and we thought
they may be gone are they flare-up we're
putting out the fires but other places
were long before us and they're now it's
like life it's got a life and we're
putting out that life because that's a
bad life that we're talking about but
all of this suggests that workers are
confident about finding a new job the
stock market is soaring with the best
gains in over 20 years in the second
quarter the Dow Jones increased 18% this
is at the quarter 8k these are not
numbers that people have heard about the
best in 33 years the S&P 500 increased
by almost 20% the best since 1998 for
the quarter and Nasdaq increase over 30%
the best since 1999 we had a 50 month if
you look over a long period of time a
phenomenal number but if you look since
the election we've gone up the Dow went
up close to 45 percent the S&P 500 went
up 47% and Nasdaq Composite went up
getting close to a hundred percent so
these are numbers that are not numbers
that other presidents would have and
they won't have it the only thing they
can kill it's a bad president or a
president that wants to raise taxes who
want to raise taxes this
thing your 401 KS will drop down to
nothing and your stock market will drop
down to nothing this is not just luck
what's happening this is a lot of talent
all of this incredible news is the
result of historic actions my
administration is taken working with our
partners in Congress to rescue the US
economy from a horrible event that was
formed took place in China and came here
and they could have stopped it they
could have stopped it nobody likes to
write that but they could have stopped
it they know it and I know it through
the Paycheck protection program we've
extended over five hundred and twenty
billion dollars in loans to nearly five
million small businesses saving and
supporting the jobs of tens of millions
of American workers this has been a
tremendous success levels that nobody's
ever seen before but we saved all of
those all of those jobs and all of those
small businesses and some will be large
businesses soon perhaps we also rushed
urgently needed relief to millions and
millions of hardworking taxpayers they
got that directly and we're working on a
phase four we're working with Congress
that work has started Steve minuchin can
give you a little briefing talking about
payroll tax cuts we're talking about
more money being infused and it comes
back to us it comes back it's all coming
back it's coming back faster bigger and
better than we ever thought possible
these are the numbers these are not
numbers made up by me these are numbers
we've implemented an aggressive strategy
to vanquish and kill the virus and
protect Americans at the highest risk
while allowing those at lower risk to
return safely to work that's what's
happening our health experts continue to
address the temporary hotspots in
certain cities and counties and we're
working very hard on that where the
relationship with the governors is very
good we made a call Mike Pence made a
call just yesterday and said what do you
need not one governor needed any
thing they don't need anything they have
all the medical equipment they can have
Thank You US government they have all of
the ventilators they have you know we're
giving many ventilators and selling in
some cases and giving when needed but
we're we're the ventilator King we're
now producing thousands of ventilators
thousands of ventilators a week and
we're helping other countries and other
countries are desperately in need of
ventilator because this is now at 189
countries that changes all the time that
number our last count is a hundred and
eighty nine countries and many of them
don't have money and they almost all of
them don't have a capacity to build a
ventilator which is hard to build very
complex very expensive very big in many
cases there we've done an incredible job
so we have assembly lines building
ventilators and we're building thousands
a week all of these people are working
with governors and local officials to
restore best practices and that's what
we've done that includes face covering
social distancing testing and personal
hygiene wash your hands state officials
will decide how rapidly to open their
economies that's largely up to them if
we see something that's egregious we've
gotten involved with a couple of them
what we thought it was unfair we'd like
to see churches opened quickly and some
of them just don't want to do that in
New York we got a great ruling from a
judge thank you judge that they can open
if these best practices are implemented
then the hot spots can be calmed quickly
and we understand this horrible disease
right now we didn't understand the
disease at all we did the right thing we
closed it up we would have lost millions
of lives we've done a historic thing we
would have lost millions of lives and
now we're opening it up and it's opening
up far faster than anybody thought even
possible and more successfully and as I
said you're going to have a fantastic
third quarter it'll be a third quarter
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
before in my opinion and the good thing
is the numbers will be coming out just
prior to the election so people will be
able to see those numbers
the fourth-quarter likewise will be
extremely good and maybe most
importantly from the standpoint of our
country itself next year will be a
historic year next year is going to be
an incredible year for jobs for
companies for growth things are
happening like nobody would have thought
possible I do want to comment Boeing as
you know is moving along in their
process it's been a very hard process a
very complicated progress but process
but they have made tremendous tremendous
gains and they're going for approvals on
the aircraft the 737 max they're also
starting to do some real business so I
just want to congratulate Boeing they've
been through so much I think it was
probably the greatest company in the
world I used to say it was the greatest
company in the world and then it ran
through a very tough period of time but
I just want to say that Boeing is made
tremendous progress in a short period of
time and other companies I don't even
have to talk about because they're all
setting records everyone virtually every
one of our great companies is setting
records so I want to thank everybody for
being here today these are historic
numbers in a time that a lot of people
would have wilted they would have wilted
but we didn't wilt and our country
didn't wilt and I'm very honored to be
your president and thank you very much
so let me just make some additional
comments and first of all we couldn't be
more pleased with the results today
again between this month and last month
that's about eight million jobs eight
million people we put back to work
because of the cares Act and working
with Congress I think as you know people
thought we would have 30 million people
unemployed fortunately we never got to
that so eight million jobs back but our
work is not done our work won't be done
till every single American who lost
their job because of covet gets back to
work and there's no question I want to
thank the Senate and the house for
working with us there's no question
these programs are working
I also want to thank them for extending
the PPP as I've said it's it's our
priority when we get to the cares for
bill in July we will look to work with
the House and Senate on a bipartisan
basis to repurpose that money we have
about a hundred and thirty billion left
there are going to be a number of
businesses that are particularly
hard-hit and we'll be looking to give
those businesses additional money so
cares for will be much more targeted for
the businesses they continue to need to
work but there there is no question that
this is working and we look forward to
continuing this progress again I think
eight million jobs really extraordinary
now let me just make one other comment
director Kudlow and I are not wearing
masks up here because we've both been
tested this morning okay and that's the
only reason but even with that we did
social distance so I'm pleased to see
you're all wearing masks I'm gonna let
director Kudlow make a few comments and
then we'll both be happy to take
questions thanks Steven just briefly
underscoring these high frequency
indicators you know it's a difficult
thing to do we haven't had much
experience with these pandemics but I
will say this the Apple mobility index
is very important index it's a real
literally a real-time daily indicator
and we're not seeing any declines it's
still strengthening even I might add in
some of the southwestern states which
have difficult hotspots housing demand
and housing surveys are just soaring
automobile demand now expected for the
third quarter about ten million plus
production units the trucking surveys
look very very strong and the Dallas Fed
survey I don't recall if it was in the
president's notes because it's obviously
in Texas a bad hot spot the Dallas Fed
survey which goes to the end of the
month has not yet shown any declines now
it may I'm not gonna rule that out and I
would say as a general matter these job
numbers as good as they are erasing a
third to a half of those who are
unemployed there's still a lot of
hardship and a lot of heartbreak in
these numbers I understand that and the
economy is on its
way back we have a ways to go I will
however continue to reference the
Congressional Budget Office which is
looking for a very strong third quarter
and second half and a number of private
surveys and private forecasters who see
the same story on the v-shape recovery
and with good policies in leadership
2020 one can be a big bang here and we
will be able to get back to the peak
levels of 2019 so I believe we're well
positioned I think we have a lot more
work to do I get that and as Steven
mentioned we'll see how the policy
discussions go later this month Thanks
I'm starting to see new unemployment
claims rising we're at one point four
million layoffs last week and that
number is actually going off not going
down let me just say I want to say we're
going to be concerned till every single
person is back to work now when you look
at these numbers I think it's tough
enough to predict economic numbers in
normal times in these times you have to
look at all these numbers in the
entirety so what I would say on that is
there's a lag on the unemployment claims
I think you also know many of these
states we set up front are completely
backed up so now I would focus on the
jobs numbers are the most accurate
numbers the trend of 8 million chops
back but having said that I'm concerned
until we get everybody back to work
obviously this is good news today no
question about it but it's also obvious
that the crisis that is surging through
Sunbelt States record number of cases
that nationally yesterday threatens all
of these economic games many states are
throwing their reopening until diverse
what additional actions is the
administration going to take to stop
that will the administration and the
president specifically call on Americans
to wear masks and why don't we have
rather than you guys celebrating good
news that has already happened why don't
we have a corona buyers task force up
here giving briefings on how
get under control when it's obviously
not under control as hepatology said
this week well let me just say I am on
the coronavirus task force so I'm happy
to answer a few of those questions I
can't comment on this schedule of
briefings I'm not aware of that
the president specifically put in his
speech encouraging Americans to wear
masks social distance and hygiene
because he's the president the United
States and people are not around him
close and the people who are around are
tested I don't think he needs to wear a
mask but the rest but the room but the
rest of us absolutely and the president
supports wearing masks I was at the
house this week testify I'm sure you saw
my picture with cher Powell on the The
Wall Street Journal I never thought we'd
have a picture like that but yes we are
encouraging Americans to wear masks now
unlike last time as I've said and yes I
realized the numbers of cases we're
monitoring that carefully we're
monitoring the hospital capacity let me
just say I've been briefed on where we
are on vaccines and virals I'm very
encouraged we'll have things by the end
of the year so yes we're going to be
careful and I wouldn't say reverse I
would say the states appropriately are
pausing certain things like bars and
gyms which obviously are the more
contagious types of things and I think
the states are acting appropriately so
they have put a team in play and CDC is
doing more of that and what they're
doing is working with local officials
government officials but health
officials to really re-emphasize what I
call the list of best practices and I
think that will do the trick and if you
have to phase out the Steven so just
days out bars so be it for a few weeks I
think some places might have been over
exuberant and now have to come back and
get back to these best practices of
distancing and masks and testing and
have personal hygiene we're getting this
under control it is obvious to anyone
watching City was not under control and
Anthony thought she said so obviously I
think what dr. pouchy said is that if
people don't take these things seriously
okay that the numbers could continue to
spike so again what I'd say is the
numbers are up we're obviously watching
this very carefully we think that there
is the right balance and we're working
with the states on the health issues and
the economic issues we'll go to the next
question yes mr. secretary there is a
reference every day does the White House
regret
encouraging States to open as quickly no
absolutely not
I think we've had a very careful plan
again working with the states this is
primarily the state's responsibility but
working with the states and again I
think there's plenty of places we can
get people back to work safely I can
tell you in the Treasury we're going to
take more people back we are social
distancing we're checking people's
temperature at times there is a safe way
to reopen the economy and we're going to
do that carefully what is the
administration doing about this how are
you working on it or their strategies
they're trying to employ we're working
with schools and universities again I
think in most cases schools will be able
to open safely some schools will need to
spend money one of the things we'll look
at and cares for is if we need to give
money to schools to properly equip their
areas I think that's something that will
be high absolutely we want we want to
make sure that kids are safe and that if
there is money that schools need to
spend to safely have people in
classrooms social distance spread things
out change hours these are all the
things we're looking at can you assess
the current need for American families
in a phase four bill and in the spring
you said that a very big number was
needed what's the current me I think
it's too early to tell and that's the
reason why we're we're waiting
we spent an unprecedented amount of
money we have authorization of three
trillion dollars that's an extraordinary
amount of money a lot of that money is
not in the economy yet we're continuing
that's why we're extending things like
the PPP and before we go back to
Congress and I'm already having
conversations with certain members of
Democrats and Republicans to get ideas
but we want to see the economic numbers
as I said earlier people thought we were
going to have 30 million people
unemployed right now fortunately we're
about 15 million unemployed we had 5
million people unemployed before this so
we got 10 million people to put back to
work
the president's committed to do what we
need to do in the next bill to protect
kids protect jobs protect liability yes
in the back he tweeted a video of a
supporter yelling white power
he's been tweeting a veto threat if the
chamilitary bases are named away from
Confederate generals he's been tweeting
a lot about Confederate statues and not
wanting them to come down we're in the
middle of the pandemic is the president
more focused on preserving or
celebrating the Confederacy than getting
this pandemic under control let me just
say I think the president's focused on
everything I think this issue of statues
and everything else is a complicated
issue there was an op-ed in the Wall
Street Journal from the the Cardinal in
New York about the Bible and everybody
other than Mary and Jesus Christ I think
it's a very complicated issue we need to
have a balanced view of history we're
here to talk about economics we'll take
one more question in the back yes the
Treasury Department on sending stimulus
check who makes that as families there's
a lawsuit that's a lot of difference eat
are you guys going to be doing that
anytime soon or you're going to leave it
to the courts to decide whether the
Treasury Department has to do it I'm
sorry I didn't understand the question
what was the question on stimulus checks
makes that his family so parents
ovendonkey of American citizen child
children people who are married
position is that legal Americans
American citizens should get the
payments that's our focus if people are
here illegally they're not going to get
economic payments so well but let me
just say we're very focused on as part
of the next cares Act we're gonna
seriously consider whether we need to
put more payments and direct payments
over worked very well thank you
everybody